but vulnerability is not just about fear
and grief and disappointment it's the
birthplace of everything we're hungry
for I've just never done anything that's
turned out to be valuable that wasn't
just scared less to do it like
everything I've ever done that's ever
really made a contribution I have felt
alone in doing it and
afraid but I walk on the stage I'm gonna
talk about things that 90% of the people
in the audience have never thought about
talked about and are scared to listen to
wanna soar get a mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best brené Brown and five pieces of her
best life-changing advice meant to me
Brene all right let's kick it off with
rule number one
embrace vulnerability we think about
vulnerability as a dark emotion you know
there are a lot of feet people who talk
about light ammo you know positive
emotions negative emotions dark emotions
light emotions we think of vulnerability
as a dark emotion we think of it as the
core of fear and shame and grief and
disappointment uncertainty things that
we do not want to feel right things that
I don't want to be vulnerable because
that means I'm afraid that means I'm
uncertain that means I'm like I'm at
risk I'm exposed I'm in grief so what we
do is we armor up and we say I do not
want to slip into these dark emotions I
will not let myself be vulnerable but
here's what I learn from the research
and certainly put into motion in my own
life that was the most life-changing is
that vulnerability is the center of
difficult emotion but it's also the
birthplace of every positive emotion
that we need in our lives
love belonging joy empathy how many of
you would agree that we're in a serious
empathy deficit in our culture today
totally right no vulnerability no
empathy in a culture where people are
afraid to be vulnerable you can't have
empathy your empathy is not a default
response if you share something with me
that's difficult in order for me to be
truly empathic I have to step into what
you're feeling and that's vulnerable so
there can be no empathy without
vulnerability why do you think in that
example that I used while ago daughter
comes home and says you know tears no
one sat with me at lunch
today they made fun of what I was
wearing so-and-so won't talk to me they
poured my books out of my locker and the
response back is I told you I bought you
all those cute jeans why aren't you
wearing those jeans and pull your hair
back
is that an empathic response no it's a
shaming response could that was shaming
response be if it could get a mother who
absolutely adores her child respond with
that shaming response
please say yes don't kid yourself I mean
come on if you've got a if you're a
parent sitting in here then you sure as
hell know the answer that is yes but why
why did that happen what where was the
access to vulnerability where was I mean
where was empathy you can't access
empathy if you're not willing to be
vulnerable so my daughter comes home and
tells that to me guess what I have to do
I have to reactivate that sweaty palms
seventh grader who lives inside me and I
have to go oh god that's so hard I'm so
sorry
that's happened to me that's happened to
me when I was in middle school and it's
happened to me last week let's talk
about it but you can't get there without
vulnerability you can't fake empathy
innovation and creativity born of
vulnerability this is my favorite part I
talked about this and then I did another
TED talk this year in Long Beach and I
told the story that during 2011 and even
this year after the big TEDx Houston
talk went viral the big calls came from
fortune 500 companies oh my god we loved
your TED talk it was great please come
talk to all of our senior leaders and
just like okay
um what do you talk about like we don't
care just come and talk to us just if
you could explain and vulnerability talk
every single conversation
barring maybe 10% like what what do you
mean well we well you know you're you
know you're funny you have this great
research I think there's a real fit with
what we do we just we don't really do
you know that kind of stuff around here
so you if you could not mention
vulnerability and shame so just for fun
for grins I would say okay so what would
you like me to talk about yeah
fourth-quarter earnings like freakin
don't even balance my checkbook um like
I'm not gonna talk about that so what do
you what do we what do you let me talk
about well the big issue creativity and
innovation mmm and change we're going
through a lot of change like okay so
vulnerability is the birthplace of
creativity innovation change and the
reason that crisis is happening is
because you're not talking about
vulnerability imagine creativity and
innovation without vulnerability I'm
asking you for a work product that has
never been made before that's completely
innovative I need you to be creative and
then as you presented to a group of
people who are gonna have I'm gonna
think it's stupid and not understand it
know vulnerability their rule number two
be authentic when I talk when I do a lot
of leadership work I talk about
understand your personal values and my
two personal values are faith and
courage and so they say don't talk about
faith it's inappropriate it's this is a
you know an organic corporate
corporation and then I'll I do a lot of
work in churches and they'll say don't
cuss and so I just got to the point
where I'm like look I've said across
from thousands and thousands of people
over the last two decades of my life
listening to the hardest things you can
imagine and the two things that everyone
has in common when they're talking about
those things are cussing and praying if
you don't want me to cuss and you don't
want me to pray that's awesome
ask somebody else because what I'm not
going to do is get up and [ __ ] you
and there are a million people in this
space who who are better than I am who
know different things than I do invite
them
if you need me to wear a suit that's I
totally get it
I'm not gonna do that yeah yeah I'm
gonna wear jeans and boots and probably
I'll wear a nice shirt yeah um but I'm
not gonna do that because I don't get up
there when I speak in public I don't get
up there to talk to my you know to talk
from my Brooks Brothers self to your
Brooks brother self I get up there and
when I walk on the stage I'm gonna talk
about things that 90% of the people in
the audience have never thought about
talked about and are scared to listen to
and they need to see me as a person and
I'm just that person I think that clear
I want if you invite me I want your
event or your leadership team I want it
to be successful yes you know and if you
need me to be someone different than who
I am it's not going to be successful
also if you want to have more confidence
check out my to 54 series they're free
the links are in the description below I
call perfectionism the 2010 shield we
carried around thinking it's gonna
protect us from being hurt yeah but it
protects us from being seen we think of
vulnerability as a dark emotion we think
of it as the core of fear and shame and
grief and disappointment uncertainty
things that we do not want to feel right
you know how blame is described in the
research a way to discharge pain and
discomfort rule number three risk
failure I think there's like a thin film
of terror wrapped around us and so if
it's not I'm not safe enough I'm not
secure enough it's I'm not liked enough
I'm not promoted enough I'm not loved
enough I don't have another have enough
I am not enough at the very bottom yeah
I'm not enough yeah well that's big big
bag bag bag bag somebody ring some bells
we need some bells to ring on this show
but that's it and so guess what the
number one casualty is of a scarcity
culture what vulnerability we shut down
we shut down cuz I'm not gonna let you
know now cuz I'm not all together right
yeah
and the thing is that people like oh
well we lose a little vulnerability but
vulnerability is not just about fear and
grief and disappointment it's the
birthplace of
everything we're hungry for creativity
joy creativity faith yeah innovation and
all of that yes and the whole thing is
there is no innovation and creativity
without failure period so we got to be
open enough to take the risk to fail
yeah
rule number four brave the wilderness
I've just never done anything that's
turned out to be valuable that wasn't
just scared left to do it like
everything I've ever done that's ever
really made a contribution I have felt
alone in doing it and afraid and but
alive yeah that's a really interesting
going good tell me more about that
alive alone but alive what that's it's
sort of like the wilderness it is the
wilderness because you the metaphor for
the book is let's see if I get this
right rather than asking you am I trying
yeah check my work there's it's there's
a poetic narrative about its being wild
and risky and you have to prepare to go
there and it's also stunning and so
there's an obvious really clear
connection between that and putting
yourself out there there's risks and
rewards and beauty but there's
interesting twist if if I get this right
that it's not that you are in the
wilderness it's that you are the
wilderness explain that well I think
what I what I have found is that after
the first time and he only really takes
one time after the first time that you
opted to brave their wilderness you pull
away from what a group of people thinks
maybe it's your maybe it's your creative
community it's your critics the first
time you pull away and find power and
standing on your own I think your heart
is marked by the wild I think you belong
in into the wilderness in a different
way because every time after that when
you choose fitting in over belonging to
yourself it's painful and rule number
five the last one before a very special
bonus clip is show up my story is that I
am a researcher and I never thought I
would have a big public career and so I
do
TEDTalk that went very viral and in the
wake of that I was kind of everywhere
for a couple of months on every cnn.com
NPR it was everywhere and something I
wasn't used to and the marching orders
from my therapist and my husband were do
not read the comments online so I read
all the comments online it's a one
morning I woke up and there were two or
three new articles out and I started
reading the comments and they were
devastating they weren't about my work
they were about me they were super
personal and they were the things that
created people play in their mind and
then give up doing what they really want
to do like if I asked every single one
of you you would try what would you try
if you knew people would never say this
about you what would that what would
this be it would those were the comments
that morning of course she embraces
imperfection what choice does she have
look what look at how she looks I feel
sorry for her kids less research more
Botox just mean personal attacks the
things that really up until that moment
had inspired me to stay very small in my
life in my career just so I could avoid
those things so that morning Steve and
the kids leave I stay home I get on the
couch and I watch eight hours of Downton
Abbey and when it's over I don't want to
turn off Downton Abbey because I then
Chris ooh the minute you turn off
Downton Abbey then it's like soccer
practice and dinner and back to the mean
people and maybe should I get Botox and
maybe you know maybe if I stand still
when I talk so I get my laptop and I do
a search for who was president and you
know
States during the Downton Abbey era have
you ever done that like you you're
numbing with TV or movie and so when
it's over you just like stay in that
space by like learning more about the
actors and what's going on I've been
doing this long enough to know this is
like you're laughing with me so I put it
in and Theodore Roosevelt comes up and a
quote comes up and I read it and this is
what it says it's a quote from a speech
that he gave in the early nineteen
hundred's of the Sorbonne and a lot of
people called them in the arena speech
and this is the passage that changed
changes my life it's not the critic who
counts it's not the man who points out
how the strong man stumbles or where the
doer of Deeds could have done it better
the credit belongs to the person who's
actually in the arena whose face is
marred with blood and sweat and dust who
at the best in the end knows the triumph
of high achievement and who at worst if
he fails he fails daring greatly so the
moment that I read that I closed my
laptop and this is what shifted in me
three huge things first I spent the last
twelve years studying vulnerability and
that quote was everything I know about
vulnerability it is not about winning
it's not about losing it's about showing
up and being seen the second thing this
is who I want to be I want to create I
want to make things that didn't exist
before I touch them I want to show up
and be seen in my work and in my life
and if you're going to show up and be
seen there is only one guarantee and
that is you will get your ass kicked
that is the guarantee that's the only
certainty you have if you're gonna go in
the arena and spend any time in there
whatsoever especially if you've
committed to creating in your life you
will get your ass kicked so you have to
decide at that moment I think for all of
us if courage is a value that we hold
this is a consequence
you can't avoid it the third thing which
really set me free and I think Steve my
husband would argue has made me somewhat
dangerous it's kind of a new philosophy
about criticism which is this if you're
not in the arena also getting your ass
kicked I'm not interested in your
feedback I've got a special bonus tip
from Renee on how to not be a
perfectionist that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to take an
action here we go question number one
where do you need to embrace
vulnerability number two what failure do
you need to risk today and question
number three how can you show up for
yourself and your family this week how
many of you struggle with perfectionism
a little bit okay
so my favorite story is that someone
sent me an email one time that said hey
I know you have a book on shame not so
interested in that but when if you ever
write on perfectionism I can't wait so
here's the here's the secret
when perfectionism is driving shame is
always riding shotgun and fears the
annoying backseat driver say it again
when when perfectionism is driving shame
is always riding shotgun we struggle
with perfectionism in areas where we
feel most vulnerable to shame does that
make sense so we're all comforting you
have a little perfectionistic which is
code for like I do things really well
but I don't really I'm not comfortable
saying I have shame perfectionism what
is that I call it the 20-ton shield
here's what perfectionism really is it's
a way of thinking that says this if I
look perfect live perfect work perfect I
can avoid or minimize criticism blame
and ridicule whoa that's good all
perfectionism is is the 20-ton shield
that we carry around hoping that it'll
keep us from being hurt when in truth
what it does is it keeps us from being
seen and so we had a great talk about
what's the difference between
perfectionism yes because somebody on my
staff had the nerve to tell me that I
was a perfectionist
I absolutely deny that and you stood by
me thank you very much because I'm not
perfectionist I'm a person who strives
for excellence and requires excellence
there there is a difference is there not
there is a difference here's the
difference because sometimes I'm a
healthy Stryver yeah and sometimes I'm a
perfectionist it depends on if I'm
feeling if I've got a worthiness crunch
going on so healthy striving is
internally focused it's I want to do
this and be the best I can be
perfectionism is not about what I want
it's perfectionism is exactly what will
people think
if you want to learn the power of
vulnerability and emotions with Bernie
Braun check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there to me these are the most
profoundly dangerous questions that we
Center our lives around